And I think the correct answer here is this one above.
Again, it's a bit subjective using these small examples,
but otherwise it's just too complicated for you to see and explain.
So my point here is basically this,
if you have decided what you're going to do with x1, x2, and x3,
then the following thing happens.
You've already decided what you're going to do with x1,
you've already decided what you're going to do with x2,
and you've already decided what you're going to do with x3,
and in that case, what remains is an instance of 2-SAT,
and that is solvable in polynomial time.
Of course this is a very simple example,
so you could have already figured out how to solve it.
So there's many different ways to solve it,
but I just wanted to show you what I mean by distance
of a 3-SAT instance to a 2-SAT instance,
because over here you decide what to do with these values.
Well, you have it figured out for this clause here,
you have it figured out for this one here,
but you have not figured it out for that one here.
So in a way, the above formula is closer to a
polynomial-time solvable instance of SAT than the one down here.
But of course you would need a really, really large and tedious
Boolean formula to actually take advantage of this.
But in fact, many professional SAT solvers or SAT solving packages
actually make use of this fact.
There are a number of variants of SAT
that are known to be solvable in polynomial time,
and what these solvers do is they will try to figure out
if the Boolean formula that they are given is actually close
to one of those polynomial-time solvable instances.
Actually, I don't even know if somebody has considered
this as a parameter for fixed-parameter tractability,
so there might actually be an open research
problem for you here if you're ready to get into it.